if you're still making your chicken
salad with mayo
you're doing it wrong tahini chicken
salad is the only recipe you need for
any barbecues picnics or tailgates this
summer I don't actually know what
happens at a tailgate but us Canadians
love the idea of it
so I'm going to show you how to make it
all right we start with our tahini
we got some lemon juice
maple syrup lots of salt some pepper and
a little bit of water to thin it out
we're going to add in some shredded
rotisserie chicken some chopped Granny
Smith apple some celery ripe grapes
green onions and a handful of sliced
almonds give it a toss then you take
your retro style Iceberg goblets and
filler up that's what she said this is
like the sexy love child between your
mom's chicken salad and some kind of
retro 1970s Waldorf but of course with
little upscale Middle Eastern Flair and
the best part is you don't have to
interact with mayo
mayo and me we're not friends
oh my God